Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
« Ubérisation, à qui le tour ? »
C'est la question qui nous a été posée
à Clément Bertholet et à moi,
en dernière année de formation
du Corps des Mines.
Alors on a mené notre enquête.
On a interviewé les gens de différents
secteurs, et une chose nous a marqués :
on s'accorde tous pour dire
que tout va finir par se faire ubériser,
mais dès qu'il s'agit
de notre propre secteur,
on trouve toujours une raison
pour qu'il y échappe.
L'idée est venue petit à petit.
Au début, on n'osait pas trop en parler ;
on rigolait en imaginant l'accueil salé
que nous réserverait le jury
de hauts fonctionnaires
devant lequel on allait
défendre nos travaux.
Et puis on a dû se rendre à l'évidence :
notre secteur à nous, Clément et moi,
l'État, était en train
de se faire ubériser.
Ubériser, c'est-à-dire ?
Après nous être rendu
compte qu'ubérisation
n'était ni synonyme de désintermédiation,
ni d'économie collaborative,
ni d'économie à la demande,
nous avons défini l'ubérisation
comme la disruption
rapide du modèle existant
par une plateforme numérique
de confiance tournée vers le client
et sans infrastructure
physique, ni opérateurs.
Uber et BlaBlaCar n'ont
ni voiture, ni chauffeur.
Et effectivement, tous
les services publics de l'État
sont en train de se faire ubériser,
le plus souvent par les GAFA :
santé, éducation, transports collectifs...
Même la justice ou la sécurité,
le régalien n'est pas épargné.
Alors, ça peut paraître
anodin, mais le safety check
mis en place par Facebook
en cas de crise majeure
est finalement plus efficace qu'un
traditionnel numéro vert gouvernemental.
D'ailleurs, le soir du 13 novembre,
Facebook a demandé l'autorisation au
gouvernement français avant de l'activer,
et a reçu plus de 4 millions de
signalements en moins de 24 heures.
Alors d'accord, mais est-ce
qu'ubériser les services publics,
c'est ubériser l'État ?
En tout cas, les GAFA
ont certaines caractéristiques
qui les rapprochent des États :
ils ont un nombre
considérable d'utilisateurs
qui à bien des égards pourrait
être assimilé à une nation ;
ils ont une puissance
financière absolument colossale ;
et puis ils semblent aussi
souvent faire du développement.
C'est par exemple Facebook
avec son programme internet.org
qui offre un accès gratuit à Internet
aux populations de certains
pays en développement.
On pourrait se dire : « Tant mieux,
au final, les GAFA, sous bien des aspects,
sont mieux armés que les gouvernements
pour répondre aux défis du XXIe siècle. »
Mais on pense qu'il est important d'avoir
en tête un certain nombre de limites.
D'une part, les GAFA
sont souvent considérés
comme le bras armé
du gouvernement américain,
encore plus depuis l'affaire Snowden.
D'autres pensent que
les GAFA sont des businessmen,
là avant tout pour maximiser
la valeur pour leurs actionnaires.
Le cas de Facebook qui
installe Internet en Afrique
mais ne respecte pas
la neutralité d'Internet
en restreignant l'accès à un nombre très
limité de sites, dont évidemment Facebook,
est quand même assez significatif.
D'autres personnes pensent aussi
que, au moins sur certains projets,
les GAFA sont purement dans
une logique philanthropique.
Alors comme d'habitude, la vérité, c'est
certainement un mélange des trois options.
Mais en fait là n'est pas du tout la
question, parce que, dans tous les cas,
ça pose la question primordiale
des liens entre technologie et politique.
Il serait absolument faux de croire
que, pour un problème donné,
la solution passe nécessairement
par une réponse technologique.
Prenons l'exemple d'une balance
connectée qui vous dirait :
« Vous avez pris
cinq kilos en une semaine,
vous avez 30 % d'offerts
sur ces baskets Nike
et au Club Med gym pour y remédier. »
Alors génial ! la technologie
pousse à l'activité physique,
mais quid du lobbying anti-fast-food,
de l'éducation alimentaire
à l'école primaire, etc.
C'est pourquoi une résolution politique
et collective est absolument nécessaire,
sans quoi l'État sera ubérisé
d'une façon qui ne nous ressemble pas.
Nous avons pensé à nous arrêter là :
« Ubérisation, à qui le tour ? À l'État. »
Mais nous serions passés à côté
d'une incroyable opportunité,
celle de considérer le phénomène
d'ubérisation tel qu'il est,
c'est-à-dire un vecteur
formidable de changement
auquel il faut juste que nous donnions
une direction et des valeurs.
Montesquieu disait :
« La nature de l'État
dépend de l'étendue de l'espace. »
En l'occurrence, l'espace, il a changé.
Pour une fois, les distances
n'ont pas été diminuées
par tel nouveau moyen de transport,
elles ont carrément été supprimées.
Donc l'État lui aussi doit
absolument changer de paradigme.
Pour Clément et moi,
l'État doit s'auto-ubériser.
C'est-à-dire que l'État doit
construire des plateformes numériques
qui sont tournées vers le client -
ici, le citoyen, nous tous -
et qui sont sans infrastructure
physique, ni opérateur.
C'est ce qu'essaie déjà de faire
le Secrétariat Général à la
modernisation de l'action publique,
et son incubateur de start-ups d'État
duquel est sortie
la plateforme mes-aides.gouv.
En quelques clics, vous
pouvez savoir rapidement
à quelles aides vous êtes
éligible - APL, RSA, etc. -
extrêmement rapidement et indépendamment
de l'organisme qui les distribue.
C'est aussi ce qu'essaie de faire
le ministère de l'éducation brésilien,
qui a choisi non d'embaucher des
professeurs d'anglais supplémentaires,
mais d'instaurer des discussions par Skype
entre élèves et retraités américains.
Mais être Uber-État,
malheureusement, ne suffit pas
parce que, plus que Uber et les autres,
ce sont en fait les GAFA
qui agrègent toute la valeur.
Tout simplement, Uber n'existerait pas
sans les infrastructures technologiques
bâties par les GAFA.
Son système de géolocalisation
se base sur Google Maps,
ses chauffeurs utilisent Waze,
on télécharge l'application
sur l'Apple Store,
on paie via Apple Pay si on veut,
on s'y connecte directement
avec ses identifiants Facebook,
et les données sont gérées
par Amazon Web Services.
Donc finalement,
Uber, BlaBlaCar et Airbnb, c'est
seulement la partie émergée de l'iceberg
qui repose sur l'échafaudage des GAFA,
ces plateformes qui ont construit
des infrastructures indispensables
auxquelles d'autres
plateformes se connectent.
On s'est inspiré des théories existantes,
et on a choisi d'appeler les GAFA
des méta-plateformes,
c'est-à-dire des plateformes
de plateformes,
en l'occurrence satellites,
qui leur gravitent autour comme Uber.
Et c'est plus intéressant d'en être une
car les méta-plateformes
gagnent à tous les coups.
On prend souvent
la métaphore de la forêt :
quand des moineaux arrivent sur une forêt,
on ne sait pas sur quel arbre ils vont
se poser ; c'est aléatoire, incertain.
Chaque arbre, c'est
une plateforme satellite,
et l'intégralité de la forêt,
c'est la méta-plateforme.
L'Apple Store - méta-plateforme -
ouvre son code à des
applications - plateformes satellites -
et en retour prend 30% de commission
sur toutes leurs transactions financières.
Donc non seulement, peu importe
quelle app les clients choisissent -
qu'importe l'arbre que les
moineaux choisissent pour se poser -
la méta-plateforme n'est pas
soumise à la loi des usages.
Et surtout la méta-plateforme profite
de tout le contenu produit
en extérieur par ces apps
pour être extrêmement efficace
et attrayante, quasiment sans effort,
juste en ayant rendu son code adressable.
Alors quel rapport avec l'État ?
Eh bien, le fait que ces deux
caractéristiques de la méta-plateforme -
être plus efficace et incontournable -
nous amène à dire qu'après,
et en plus de s'ubériser,
l'État doit se méta-plateformiser,
devenir « m-état-plateforme »,
pour être plus efficace,
c'est-à-dire ajouter aux
plateformes satellites publiques
créées en interne - comme mes-aides.gouv -
l'ingéniosité et l'agilité
de plateformes satellites privées,
et puis pour être incontournable,
c'est-à-dire ne pas subir son ubérisation,
mais la vivre dans un cadre de valeurs
jugées acceptables par la collectivité.
Et en fait, là où nos
prédécesseurs ont construit
des réseaux d'eau et d'électricité,
nous, il faut absolument qu'on construise
l'infrastructure d'aujourd'hui,
c'est-à-dire un réseau d'API
qui permet de rendre adressable les outils
et les données que l'État possède,
et qu'il puisse non pas commander
par le haut, comme actuellement,
mais organiser par le bas.
Et là où l'ubérisation
permettait de répondre
à tel petit problème avec telle petite
plateforme spécifique, conjoncturellement,
la méta-plateformisation
permet de répondre structurellement
en modifiant en profondeur
le squelette de l'État.
Et alors comment s'assurer
que ces plateformes satellites privées
servent bien l'intérêt général ?
En fait, plein de nouveaux types
de partenariats sont possibles.
Je vais vous en présenter quelques-uns
sur l'exemple de la start-up Finamatic
avec laquelle on a travaillé
pendant quelques mois
pour mettre en pratique concrètement
notre théorie de l'État méta-plateforme.
Ils sont partis d'un chiffre simple :
73 % des entreprises
ne connaissent pas les financements
publics auxquels elles sont éligibles.
C'est un maquis de 1 500
aides, nationales, locales,
dans lequel il est finalement
très, très difficile de se retrouver.
Leur premier service
gratuit est le suivant :
à la manière de mes-aides.gouv,
mais cette fois-ci pour une entreprise,
Finamatic nous donne une roadmap
qui vous permet de savoir
à quelles aides vous êtes
éligible et dans quel ordre.
Le second service,
qui permet de faire gagner
du temps à toutes les entreprises,
est celui du pré-remplissage
de formulaires.
Par exemple, quand vous avez
rempli le formulaire « French Tech »,
il ne vous reste que 10 % du formulaire
« Prêt d'amorçage » à compléter.
Et enfin Finamatic donne
accès à une vraie marketplace
à laquelle chaque client participe
et peut faire appel à des
experts qui sont payés à l'heure.
Tout ça en dynamique
afin d'accompagner le projet
tout au long de sa vie.
On a rencontré Finamatic,
et on avait déjà rencontré
le Secrétariat Général
à la modernisation de l'action publique.
Et on a été frappés par le fait que les
logiques étaient proches des deux côtés.
Donc on a organisé une rencontre,
non sans appréhension, la logique étant :
« Voici les gens qui cherchent
à vous ubériser. »
Et puis finalement,
ça a extrêmement bien collé.
Plein de partenariats sont, maintenant,
en cours de développement.
D'une part, l'État pourrait
labelliser Finamatic,
qui pourrait l'afficher
fièrement sur son site.
Les employés par exemple de BPI
pourraient venir sur la marketplace
pour conseiller les entrepreneurs,
et puis à l'inverse,
Finamatic apporte des dossiers
complets de qualité aux organismes,
ce qui leur évite de multiples
allers-retours extrêmement chronophages.
Et Finamatic pourrait même
donner des statistiques
sur l'efficacité de telle ou telle aide,
par exemple, combien
d'entreprises ont embauché
suite à l'obtention d'un label
« Jeune entreprise innovante » ?
Donc Finamatic, c'est un exemple
de plateforme satellite privée
qui s'allie aux plateformes
satellites publiques
et contribue à la
méta-plateformisation de l'État.
Évidemment, cette
transformation est difficile.
Elle demande un changement
radical de culture,
c'est-à-dire que là où
le numérique, pour l'instant,
a davantage été utilisé comme une rustine
pour rendre l'État
plus efficace à la marge,
les administrations doivent
le considérer comme un savoir-être
bien plus que comme un savoir-faire.
Et cette transformation
apporte son lot de questions
qui sont toutes aussi complexes
que passionnantes.
Elles doivent tout sauf nous
paralyser, l'État doit se lancer,
pivoter si nécessaire,
voire abandonner des projets ;
en tout cas, il doit apprendre en marchant
et les réponses viendront avec l'action.
Comme le dit Jean-François Caron,
le maire de Loos-en-Gohelle,
un modèle de ville durable,
il faut aller des petits
cailloux aux étoiles,
et plus précisément :
« Une étoile pour faire
rêver et donner envie,
et des petits cailloux pour mettre
en mouvement et baliser le chemin. »
L'étoile qui, là en l'occurrence,
doit guider l'action de l'administration,
c'est la méta-plateforme
et les valeurs qu'elle véhicule :
ouverture et confiance
en l'intelligence collective.
Et l'État n'y arrivera pas tout seul.
C'est à nous, individus,
entreprises, collectifs,
de faire plus que de critiquer
et de co-construire ensemble
pour proposer et faire muter.
Et non, le coup d'État n'aura pas lieu !
Pas si tous nous contribuons,
avec ceux qui le font déjà,
à l'ubérisation de l'État.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)